In this part of optimization view modes,
I'd like to talk about lighting complexity
as lighting complexity shows you how many non-static lights
you have affecting your geometry.
Remember, a non-static light is
a light that is dynamic or can move around and interact
with the scene in real time.
Now, the more non-static lights
you have affecting any piece of geometry,
the more expensive it will be to render.
Red means areas are going to have performance issues.
And as we start to hit red to light purple, dark purple,
and then on to white, this is going
to be very expensive to render.
So this is definitely something we need to look at.
Now, again, as with most of our optimization view modes,
the goal here is to identify possible areas
and see what we can do to help adjust them in order
to get some performance back.
However, we don't want to make black and white decisions.
For example, we don't need to have
the scene that's ideal to moderate,
as the car is the only object in the scene
at this time.
So because of that, we can get away
with going to the more expensive and very expensive.
And also, every scene is unique.
So again, these tools are used
to help us make better judgments.
And let's go ahead and jump into the engine
and see an example of that.
Here, we have that exact same scene.
And if I come over to my lit optimization view modes,
lighting complexity, and remember,
Alt 7 is the keyboard shortcut.
Look at that.
That is just insane.
Everything is white.
That's really not going to work for us.
So what we're going to do first
is I'm going to hit the G key on my keyboard.
And then I'm going to come here and start selecting lights.
And let's see what's going on.
So first off, these lights right here that I selected,
they have an attenuation radius of 1,000.
And let's go ahead and just click on this effects world.
It looks like they're here just to highlight
this wheel a little bit more.
So what I'm going to do is I'm going
to take these down to, say, 50.
So with that done, let's just see what that did.
Let's just come here to our lighting complexity and see.
That didn't really do too much.
But I do know that we are well
on our way to making some adjustments that will work.
So let's grab this light next.
So this is a box light.
And look how big its radius is.
Its radius actually goes all the way out into the world.
And what we're going to do with this one
is we're just going to bring this back down.
I'm actually going to bring it quite far in,
because it looks like if I was to disable this,
it's really just to highlight this side of the car.
So having it go all the way through like this
is probably not something that we necessarily want.
Also, it gives us really hard shadow in the background.
And that doesn't really happen anywhere else in the scene.
So I'm going to bring this back in.
And check this out.
When I bring this back in and kind of just
make sure that it's right around the car,
I go back to my optimization view modes.
And I'm still not getting so much,
but we are getting some in this area.
So let's kind of continue on, because I'm sure there's
some other lights that we can do.
So let's check out this one right here.
Attenuation radius, 2,500.
So that's pretty large too.
That's going all the way out there.
Let's go back.
So this looks like, again, it's trying
to get the front right there.
So we're just going to bring this down.
It's about right there.
There we go.
Let's see.
What else can we do?
Let's grab the spotlight.
So it looks like it's actually going through the floor.
So again, we'll just take this attenuation radius
and bring this up, because it looks like it's probably
going right there for that highlight,
the front kind of right there.
You can see it's giving it just a little bit
of extra light.
There we go, something like that.
Nice.
All right, let's just check this out one more time,
because this is a process that is iterative.
So still getting a lot of red in there, or a lot of white,
I should say.
So let's see what else we can do over here.
So we fixed these ones.
Let's check this one out.
So what is this?
Sorts, this is a big one.
So let's go ahead and see what
this is doing really quick by just disabling it and enabling
it so it's casting on the back here.
So let's just bring this down some more,
because it looks like, oh, yeah, that was definitely
affecting everything in the scene.
Let's go back here, see our optimization view modes.
I'm still not crazy expensive, so let's
keep on going with these.
This one's got a huge attenuation radius as well,
and it's only for the other side of the car.
So there we go, maybe like that.
Let's see what we're doing with our lighting complexity now.
Nope, still pretty complex, but look,
we're getting better on the sides here,
so let's keep going.
We have these inner lights here.
Looks like these inner lights, let me just
grab these really quick, and let's go ahead
and see what affects the world.
So these are to brighten up the inside of the car,
and their attenuation radius is set to 1,000.
So let's set these to 50, and let's just
see, probably 75.
That definitely looks like they're doing their job,
and let's go back and check our attenuation,
or not attenuation, I'm sorry, lighting complexity again.
Oh my gosh, look at that.
So there we go.
That was our culprit.
That definitely helped us out quite a bit.
So that was the one final thing
that we had to bring in to help really just make sure
that we can run this scene appropriately,
to go to frame rate while not destroying
the art quality of it.
Now, the last thing I want to note about this, too,
is I'm going to come back to one of these lights.
A very important thing is this casting shadows.
Enabling and disabling casting shadows
is going to have a huge performance
impact on any dynamic light that you use.
So just as a rule of thumb, if you
want a dynamic light or your lighting complexity
to improve drastically, you can also disable cast shadows,
and that will have a huge performance
impact on that particular light.